Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. I'm Darrell Stetler.
I'm really thankful you're here, and I can't wait to teach you some of the things
that the scripture has taught me about God and His holiness.
Holiness is a mega theme of scripture, and we're going to see how incredibly
meaningful this concept is and how it changes our view of God and
ourselves. Now, I want to encourage you to make sure and download
the 40-day guide, the workbook that's included with this course.
Don't just watch and listen. I want you
instead to also write. The reason that's important is because
it'll help you process and think through what the scripture's saying,
and most importantly, just help you put it into practice.
Because it's not just what you read, it's what you do of the Bible.
Here's what I'm going to imagine for this 40 days.
I'm going to imagine that you came to me and you said, "Darrell,
I really want to be a holy man, a holy woman.
I want to grow in holiness.
And I was wondering, Darrell, if you would meet with me for 40 days and just teach
me in bite-sized chunks what the scripture says about being
as holy, as much like Jesus in my heart and my life
as God can possibly make me." And I'm going to imagine that I said yes.
And so here we are. We are gathered together in a coffee shop.
I've got my iced coffee right here.
And I'm going to imagine that we've both sat down across the
table, and we're going to spend five to 10 minutes each day just talking
about holiness and what the scripture says.
I'm going to send you home with homework. That's the workbook.
Sample prayers, meditation questions, and stuff like that.
And just trust that the Holy Spirit is going to do powerful work in
you all through this 40 days.
Now, today's day one. So grab your workbook and let's get started.
From time to time, I'll scribble on my
coffee shop napkin over here. If you want to know about holiness, we have to start
with God. Day one, God is holy and the source
of all holiness. In Isaiah 6:3, we read, "Holy, holy,
holy is the Lord Almighty. The whole earth is full of His
glory." And in Revelation 4:8, we read another picture of the worship in
heaven where it says, "Day and night, they never stop saying: Holy,
holy, holy is the Lord God Almighty, who was,
and is, and is to come."
Now, it's appropriate that we take a moment and we recognize that
all holiness is built on the reality and sourced
from God. God is at His core and in His essence,
holy love. And in Heaven, these scenes from the scripture
teach us that special creations like angels call out,
"Holy, holy, holy," continually.
Now, that Trinitarian repetition of holy is significant
because it's three in one, but also because it's the only thing repeated
around God's throne in that way. He is faithful, yes, He is
powerful, He's knowledgeable, but in His essence, He is
holy. So what is that? Well, He's separate.
He's other. He's not like. He's untouched by the
faults and weakness and dependence of all other things.
He is completely other than His creation.
There's only two things in all of existence, God and creation, God and
everything else. And that utter, unique, separate
purity is His holiness. Now, out of
this flow all of His other attributes.
Everything else is eventually unfaithful, but God is faithfulness
unmixed. Everything else is dependent and needy, but
God is completely independent, unneedy.
Everything else has a spot of corruption, but God is
unmixed purity.
Everything else has its light and its darkness, its yin and its yang, but
God is completely unmixed, completely single and whole,
utterly alone in His degree of perfection.
Now, this holiness in scripture is often expressed as
incomprehensible, blinding, terrifying light or
purifying fire. To be in the presence of God's complete holiness
would literally kill your physical body, as if you'd been suddenly transported
to within 100 miles of the sun. You couldn't physically or
spiritually take the glory of His holiness.
Now, I don't mean to suggest that God's holiness is a negative thing as though it
was a source of pain or fear.
On the contrary, God's holiness is so glorious, so
joyful, so explosively brilliant that its beauty
and goodness is what's overwhelming.
The Bible tells us to worship the Lord in the beauty of holiness, not the horror
or fear of holiness. But people have often noticed that for us as
humans, there's this place where joy gets so overwhelming that
it gets close to something like terror.
Like the sheer terror as you're about to descend the world's tallest,
fastest roller coaster. Your stomach knots up and leaps up in
your throat. You can't speak, your breath is gone, and the
joy and the terror for a few moments just overwhelms you.
Now, even if you don't like roller coasters, you know what I mean.
Recently, I joined my teenage son, and we jumped off
the top of a bridge that was over a lake.
We climbed the top, and we walked the beams along the top, and we
looked down at the lake 25 feet below, and it was higher from up
there than it was from down below. And then we jumped.
And the rush, the adrenaline, the feeling of, "I think I must be crazy."
Now, maybe you're not a jump off a bridge kind of person,
but the point still stands.
The joy and the terror meet somewhere in
there. And in the same way, the joyous
terror of God's holiness would simply overwhelm you in every
way, physically, mentally, emotionally, spiritually.
It's not that it's so bad that it's scary.
It's that it's so good, it's marvelously overwhelming.
So where does God get His holiness?
Well, God's holiness doesn't come from anywhere.
It is underived. It isn't received from anything or
anywhere. Instead, God is the fountainhead, the source,
the definition of holiness. Biblically, the word
holy only means someone who is rightly related to
God in some way.
Any holiness in the world
came from God. Any holiness in an item or a
place came from God. Any holiness in a person, you can be
sure it came from God. And if you achieve any
holiness in your life, you can be sure you didn't create it.
It came from God. So God is holy. He's the source
of all holiness. And today, starting today, we're going to spend 40
days journeying deep into that holiness,
chasing the beauty and joy of His holiness and letting that
holiness seep down into us.
So I'm looking forward to it. Thanks for being here.
Take your workbook and spend the time to do the sample prayer,
think over the meditation questions, and be just continuing on in
your growth and your desire to think through these things.
And let the Holy Spirit work that work in you
as you're going through this 40 days. I'm looking forward to it.
Thanks for taking the time to be here today. See you tomorrow.